today guys this is very exciting June
30th the last day of June it's the last
day of Pride and finally we can go back
to 330 some odd days of Shame which
frankly are much better uh but when
people talk about social justice just
going completely off the rails uh
obviously there's been all these Pride
parades the last couple weeks check out
this clip is this from New York City
Pride yeah this is from New York City
Pride and listen to what these people
are chanting
[Music]
we're here
all right I suppose the quiet part out
loud I assume that was a man with the
breasts there were guys hanging out with
their wangs out in front of children all
of the stuff
um you know guys when I booked this show
and happened to be today the last day of
Pride I didn't even realize actually the
three of us happened to be gay I would
just say happen to be because we're all
friends and it actually doesn't really
come up that often when we're having
dinner or having drinks or whatever it's
just a part of our lives but this this
LGBT thing has done something so
freaking dangerous I would say to us
that it is starting to become personal
to me uh Peter how do we separate from
the lunatics here before before the
decent people on the right who I think
have come a long way on a lot of this
stuff start turning on on the average
gay per the average G and B and L
well firstosis I think we all need to
return on membership cards because I no
longer want to be part of this group
anymore this is absolutely crazy but I
think it's really nice that you think
more and more people
who are gay you're a lesbian or bisexual
rejecting this narrative that is so
extreme and also that has embraced
transgenderism which as we've discussed
is a completely different part of Human
Experience I mean it never has anything
to do with sexuality it's not actually
part of sexuality it's something
completely different so I think it's
really nice for people like yourselves
like Douglas to speak up to address
these things and really tackle them head
on and disassociate and moderate and
modulate the narrative that's happening
Douglas what do we do about this
situation I I think if I'm not mistaken
you tweeted about it not too long ago
like this thing where I can sense that
people on the right who just who came a
long way maybe they weren't cheering gay
marriage but it happened and then they
were just like all right live your life
just you know stay away from our kids in
essence you don't have to teach people
this just just live your life which is
what I thought the a just movement for
equality was all about that's what I'm
concerned about that because of these
the way these letters have been mashed
together they're going to turn and and I
don't know what the force field against
that will be well first of all I never
had membership of this yeah no me
neither I'm just saying they they Jam
these freaking letters together yeah I I
and there also is no such thing as an
lgbtqia plus person it just isn't uh
they don't exist it's a triple clown car
made up of a bunch of now dominated
certainly by a bunch of very angry
Misfits that uh clip you showed there
was there a single gay man in that clip
I don't think so right right see it was
uh people who call themselves queer who
very often are actually straight and
anarchists in some way they have no
connection to gay men or gay women uh
they believe that they need to draw
attention to themselves and bring down
the patriarchy and everything like that
that has nothing to do with being gay I
wrote about this in The Madness of
crowds where I said then there's always
been a divide in the game gay rights
movement as there was in Civil Rights
Movement between people who believed in
in basic equality and that was it and
those who believed that it was the
beginning of a step to pull down a
society now uh the Reverend Martin
Luther King and others dealt with this
in the civil rights movement and got
that out unfortunately in the gay rights
movement uh after the point of Victory
basically these these Misfits uh have
taken over because everybody else has
got a life to get on with